all I've really learned from porn is oh  yeah the pizza man is not always  delivering pizza everyone's apartment is  like worth millions of dollars I've  learned that porn is great to watch but  it's also fantasy a lesbian couple is  just waiting for someone with a dick to  come around condoms just magically  appear there's a lot of different  positions you can get into there is no  mess with anal people make weird noises  and porn talking about tennis guys it's  tennis safer work all women are double  D's RS 8 inches spans from this big to  this big all women are instantly able to  orgasm at the drop of a hat there's no  need to get consent in general usually  that's what I've learned important as  long as like the women are being treated  respectfully enjoy it yeah that's all I  know  from porn that's it I've learned that  moaning is an art form it really is like  there's a nice like sound and like  cadence to like the way that a girl  moans  [Music]